we are still waiting to get the latest
guidance on whether President Trump will
agree to an interview a special counsel
Robert Muller in the meantime the
president continues to use social media
to proclaim not only his innocence but
that of his son chief White House
correspondent John Roberts has that
story tonight good evening John Shanta
good evening to you even on vacation
president Trump continues to drive the
news cycle with single tweets that
quickly become the most talked about
topic of the day and for a president who
says he wants the mulher investigation
to go away he seems to do a lot to keep
it alive in a tweet complaining about
media coverage president Trump scoffed
at the idea that he is concerned about
the meeting my wonderful son Donald had
in Trump Tower with Russian attorney
Natalia vessel nets kya and other
Russians but it was what he added that
raised eyebrows and again thrust the
Moller investigation into the spotlight
the president tweeting this was a
meeting to get information on an
opponent totally legal and done all the
time in politics and it went nowhere
Democrat slept on the tweet as evidence
that the president's explanations of the
meeting have been incomplete at best at
worst untrue the ranking member of the
House Intelligence Committee Adam Schiff
tweeting the Russians offer damaging
info on your opponent your campaign
accepted and the Russians delivered you
then mislead the country about the
purpose of the Trump Tower meeting when
it became public now you say you didn't
know in advance none of this is normal
or credible well shift claims the
Russians delivered there is no evidence
that they delivered anything what
President Trump tweeted wasn't exactly
new either a year ago at a press
conference with French president
Emmanuel macron he gave much the same
explanation about the Trump Tower
meeting I think from a practical
standpoint most people would have taken
that meeting
it's called opposition research or even
research into your opponent a few days
later the president tweeted about it
most politicians would have gone to a
meeting like the one Don junior attended
in order to get info on an opponent
that's politics in his Sunday missive
President
Trump also again pushback on reports
that his former attorney Michael Cohen
was going to tell investigators the
president knew about that meeting at
advance President Trump tweeting I did
not know about it but the tweet did seem
to go farther than he ever has in
acknowledging the Trump Tower meeting
was about getting information on an
opponent and it has raised questions
whether seeking election help from a
foreign national may have broken the law
or at the very least that the tweets may
give ammunition to Robert Miller's
investigation into possible obstruction
of justice
the president's attorney called that
idea nonsense
instruction of justice by tweet is
absurd president has the First Amendment
right to put his opinions out there the
other big question will the president
sit for an interview with robert muller
last week muller declined the
president's attorney's proposal to ask
only about russia the election and
collusion saying he also wants to ask
questions that go to the issue of
obstruction of justice we are moving as
expeditiously as possible to make the
determination to make our recommendation
to the president the president has been
clear that he wants to interview i will
tell you his legal team is concerned and
sources tell Fox News the president's
legal team may respond as soon as
tomorrow to robert molars parameters for
an interview we'll keep you apprised of
any developments
Shannon we will watch for your breaking
news John Roberts at the White House
thank you thank you